Piper tried to attack he does and
comment and the foul didn't get the help
that they needed in the end they're by
Zamora he just reaches in you see number
four just reach there got to move your
feet and get in there
[Music]
[Applause]
there's true of God about McLemore jewel
around McLemore gets the bounce top to
get it inbounds and a turnover great
defense there by Auburn Harper ended and
exploding for two they get it out and go
no one stops the ball which has got to
be the first thing that you have to do
[Applause]
[Music]
Harper calls for the string now on the
pieces attacking his McCormack Darren
Harper coming off the screen and that
was not a J Harris
kind of lunged for a steel there and it
allowed the poor Mick to go by him you
need to be solid there it's been
affected driving it 23 why I can't
believe you bases they ran it down
pretty far and he ends up taking a tough
tough shot
[Applause]
hit four point game ten seconds to go
Tamura quick three timeout New Mexico
straight again
Oh Queen Twitter clean the buzzer Erica
and Auburn
Queen at a great look but uh bird
escapes 78 to 77